Oh
first there was contouring then there
was clown contouring then there was
candy skull contouring and now there's
tape contouring we're gonna figure out
what that's all about
it's ladylike and today we're trying
tape contouring I don't really know
anything about contouring contouring is
kind of like a bed of lies I think it
looks really good if you can do it right
I've only tried a powder contouring
thing and I think I get too shy about it
because I put it in I'm like oh that's
too drastic and so then I just blend it
all away i watch the Instagram that huda
beauty put up about tape contouring what
how I would like step-by-step
instructions I'll just have to keep
watching this over and over confuse
exactly what the tape does I guess it
just makes it so that you have the right
amount of makeup in the right places you
apply tape here here here here here here
and then you just hope for the best so I
didn't realize that we're just actually
using scotch tape oh [ __ ]
can you go like this this is the most
like precision I've ever used with
taping is usually it's just like good
tape pace is often Oh uh-huh what don't
you know
don't wait HeLa oh there's so much to
havewhat even comes next
contouring can be fun I'm having fun I
kind of feel like this is already like
off to a great start
oh wait you I like oh what's happening I
just glued them together
I didn't oh I can see how this would
work I'm gonna look like Kim I'm trying
okay we're just gonna go with it looks a
little bit like you just fell into some
mud matter I think I did the nose very
poorly I don't want to get emotionally
attached cuz it's sort of like if it
looks bad I will get
really it's too late my heart's already
in it I'm so terrified right now well I
feel like it's like brown pale Brown
tail okay all ready to go up now you're
ready no wow actually this is kind of
cool it's like super defined lines boom
you know those tiny little hairs just a
couple okay I'm gonna use the Beauty
Blender and now I think we just hit your
face up for a while all right
oh and it does nothing so good yeah I
feel good about this my hanger face to
my knives good hitting harder are we all
supposed to know how to use a beauty
blender from birth yeah Jesus Who am I
who de you just have a really tan no
you're not cupping my head do you feel
conferred totally I've never felt more
confident really which is actually trucs
I've never contoured so this is actually
the most common sort I've ever been
you look a little dead up here but mmm
you really do hold it like an artist
palette yeah just okay I don't know I'm
like very invested in your face thank
you so what you do you just spit up on
your face you feel set oh I feel set
this looks like they did some makeup on
you and you have more makeup on than
when you arrived this is what you look
like
whoo I don't want to say I'm surprised
because it's not what I didn't think you
would do a good job I feel like I've
never seen this much makeup on my face
oh I feel bad at all do you think it's
good wait wait wait yeah you kind of
like see I think I just look tan I think
I got to focus on the tape instead of
like actually focusing on like your face
I think it'd look nice Chantal did a
great job I don't know that you look
that much different but at least I
didn't make you looking worse yeah I
think is an accomplishment went from a
nine and a half to ten so oh hello face
oh oh
you definitely did a good job I think we
you blended a little bit better than I
did I think that my blending left
something to be desired
I say you in the future in convoy it's
like weird how emotional this is for me
oh my god the tape I don't think is
helpful at all I think it's just an
extra stressor the tape helped me
because if there hadn't been tape I
would not have known where to put
anything and it like raped my face I
think we did a good job
our skill set I killed it I would not do
this on daily basis I don't have time
look at the amount of tape that we
wasted oh my god this is just a small
handful of the tape that's over here
like it is a little bit a waste of tape
and make up just a little lady tested
lady man if people ask me to do this to
them on a daily basis I'll do it to them
I'll take contour anybody's [ __ ] face